but i think look we've got we've got a
lot of stories in the news i think we
should just jump right in because
we are about a week and a half away from
this election
about 50 million people it's my
understanding i've already voted
these people can't change their votes
and that's one of the craziest things
they changed the rules they put up all
this early voting they got all this mail
in voting
i'm willing to bet there's a lot of
people right now who are learning things
they couldn't have
like it was very other let me rephrase
this there's a lot of people who are
just now learning things
information that was probably suppressed
i bet there's a lot of people who
watched that debate the other night
and when donald trump said your family
was making a ton of money off these
deals these these interviews
are these emails these these meetings
you know people want to know your
brother made millions in iraq
someone probably said whoa what is that
and they couldn't hear that story
because twitter and facebook were
actively censoring it
they may have already voted and now
they're sitting there saying oh no
i already voted for this guy that's why
censorship is so crazy
and it's gonna have a huge impact in the
next 10 or so days so
uh we're here with ryan hartwig you were
a a moderator content moderator for
facebook
yeah what is what did you do what is
that yeah so as a content moderator i
mean we we see the most vile things that
you can imagine
that are on the internet so uh there was
a training for a month and they
threw us on the production floor and you
we would be seeing you know
incest videos uh snuff videos
uh i was working for a time the the
spanish queue
in latin america so i'd see a lot of
cartel violence beheadings
throat slittings um pornography so
everything that
that's horrible on the internet that's
what i would take down and delete
uh yeah does that so i've heard a lot of
people get like ptsd from watching these
videos
all day every day i have to imagine
that's messed up stuff yeah like there's
uh for at the beginning in the spanish
queue i get more like gross stuff more
graphic violence more
cartel violence but towards the end when
i switched over to the north american
side i didn't think
i didn't get as much we would get some
child pornography as well
but yeah yeah some of my co-workers i
was just talking to one the other day
who has like ptsd symptoms
but they didn't have counselors on site
counselors that would be coaching us and
giving us techniques so i don't feel
like i really had too much ptsd most of
the time i wasn't
i was i didn't bring it home at night
but but yeah it is a tough job
ian's messed up he's gone i was going
crazy
crazy what was your schedule like um so
they had
quite a few different shifts mine was
mainly the day shift
but like i'd hate to have like the night
shift like having to see that kind of
stuff because i think your brain's
different like
during the night shift how it interprets
things so we had we had all shifts yeah
so you would what would you do would you
delete videos delete posts or what yeah
i would delete videos i would delete
groups pages
i monitored the mexican presidential
election in 2018
so there was about 200 of us on the
spanish side and we were monitoring the
mexican presidential election but yeah
i could take down whole groups pages
videos posts comments
for facebook and instagram first simple
question in your experience having
worked at this company
taking down groups pages videos did you
feel there was a political bias
yeah hundred percent against uh what
political group
uh against conservatives that's just
that simple plain simple
there it is i mean the first year before
the before the
covington law firm didn't audit against
facebook they were blatant every time
trump gave a speech even the state of
the union they're like hey guys watch
out for hate speech stemming from trump
wow every everything you said and then i
mean i added
in by may of 2019 then we can go by the
time go through the timeline at some
point but
but yeah i mean i had i'd made a list
before i even decided to reach out to
like
journalists or project veritas i made a
list of about 20 examples of bias that
i'd seen
and then that list just grew and grew
and so by the time i went public four
months ago i mean the list is like
i have 30 plus clear cut examples
of bias and this this is why congressman
matt gates you know could take the
evidence i gave him
and he was able to give that to the doj
and because of that there's a criminal
referral
to the doj for mark zuckerberg criminal
yeah criminal referral
this is not civil this is criminal why
is it criminal because he this
the that referral was for alleged
perjury
because in april 2018 zuckerberg
testified that
they do not censor political speech and
they do
they sure do yeah so what's an example
of something did you ever personally
remove
american conservatives um you know yeah
uh
so for example just a quick example like
um
there's a viral video in summer of 2018
where this trump supporter got attacked
in a restaurant he was a kid like 16
year old kid was it the splashed in the
face thing
like a drink might have been uh yeah i
think he might have splashed his drink
on him
and so facebook said hey well there was
cursing in that video towards a minor so
delete the whole thing
and they even knew it was a viral video
that said hey we know this is a viral
video
showing a trump supporter being attacked
but because there's cursing
delete the whole video which
kind of fits the part it's kind of a
gray area in the policy like
we don't like cursing about it nor
that's person to person so if i'm on
facebook attacking a minor cursing of
the minor
that's different than just sharing a
video with the neutral caption
and in some of those videos the the
curse words were even bleeped out
wow so so how would you describe
yourself politically
are you conservative yeah i think more
conservative uh more like libertarian
yeah so when you were there how well
actually let me ask how long were you
were you there for doing this job yeah i
was there for just under two years
wow you were there for a while yeah
didn't get to you you're like i'm
deleting this very important stuff
that like is important for people to
know yeah it did get to me and that's
why i started making a list
on my own like hey here's some examples
that i saw
but like the policy is very nuanced so
to the average person who's
content moderator it might not stick out
but it might not be too obvious
but like once you dig down into the
policy you're like hey this is baked
into the cake
it's not just a couple of rogue
moderators who are deleting trump
content
it's built into the policy what about
leftist content
that you think should have been removed
that they told you not to remove or
allowed to stay
do you see a lot of that so
i i don't know there's a few examples of
that i mean i
obviously the most clear-cut example i
have is there's a post in 2017
actually i wasn't there at the time but
i could go back and see a post from 2017
and they're clearly saying that antifa
is not a hate organization
but it's funny because in the post
they're like hey there's a bunch of
protests being organized in like nine
american cities
there are alleged ties to antifa please
remember that antifa is not
a hate organization wow so i mean yeah i
can definitely see them
um protecting leftist viewpoints when it
comes to protests topless protests when
there's females protesting
or if there was a protest called grab
them by the ballot
they showed a bunch of females naked
protesting trump
uh a plan words for they grabbed them by
the right right
yeah yeah and so
um that would allow it so they make
newsworthy exceptions whenever they want
to
change the policy at their whim so are
they are they uh
do you think they swung any elections do
you think they swung 2018's midterms or
what
2018 was a trial run so
yeah so facebook told us and the word on
the street their facebook was hey
you know we brought all the content
moderation to the us which is very
expensive by the way
it was like a 200 million dollar
three-year contract so they brought
they brought these jobs to the u.s so
they could keep it closer on the on the
election
and the ex the reason they gave was
because russia interfered in the 2016
election
so that was the whole basis for them
bringing thousands of jobs to the u.s
was hey russia interfered in 2016 we
messed up
we're trying to fix this but in 2018
yeah we had a training deck just for the
2018 midterms
excuse me uh we have yeah we had a
training deck so they said hey flag any
content that's election related
if it's meet certain criteria flag with
a vi which goes
directly to the facebook queue to
facebook employees
so and then just this past fall they
were like they they sent us a message
saying
we urgently need visibility into
conversations about the democratic
debates
the democrat debates when the primaries
so even stuff that's not violating they
want to know what's going on where their
eyes and ears
because without us flagging trends like
i was flagging this past
january and december i was flagging like
boogaloo and civil war was trending
so we we flagged trends to them and
facebook
facebook yeah you're not just removing
stuff you're actually
like scouting intel and giving them
information what people are talking
about
exactly interesting alan was uh alan
bakari uh for those of us unfamiliar
with him on the show he's a journalist a
tech reporter for breitbart and he's
been covering a lot of this he mentioned
there's this program where they're
trying to pull
people to the center did you have you
heard about this at all
i think i heard mention of it on the
interview on tuesday so they're trying
to pull people to the center
yeah well it sounds like it you didn't
come across anything like that in your
in your work
dick actually when i act i talked to the
policy manager sean i had a lot of
conversations with him he was in charge
of
of the he was a cognizant employee but
he could make decisions for like
the entire you know all the staff at the
phoenix location
so he can make a decision for a thousand
workers about the policy
and so i asked him about that and he's
like yeah we try to like segregate
people like like-minded people together
to prevent more yeah that's why they're
they're tribalizing people on purpose
yeah why he said like to prevent i don't
know maybe
fights prevent conflict or whatnot
because i raised up civil war to him the
trending civil war
this was during the impeachment and
people were talking about boogaloo which
kind of means civil war right right
he's like that's great like keep on
sending me these jobs facebook really
wants visibility he wants to know what's
going on
he's like if facebook had identified
some of these trends in 2016
then they would have been glad to know
what the trends were in 2016 when trump
won
the the thing i'm curious about when
hearing you know ellen was saying that
basically what they're trying to do is
they were trying to figure out why
people who are far right became more
moderate
regular conservative whatever and they
wanted to find whatever content they
were viewing
and give them more of it so i'm
wondering if
did they ever come to you and say this
content clearly
breaks the rules like i understand you
mentioned the leftist
protest but i'm wondering if there was
other examples where they said
these things get a special exemption
like straight up told you
don't get rid of this kind of content
um i'm trying to think of some examples
like that because i know
i know they gave news over the
exceptions like like if you know there
were celebs
uh opposing abortion alabama and they
said something that violated the policy
then then facebook gave them a pass we
can go back to that later if you like uh
discussing abortion but
so they gave specific newsworthy
exceptions to promo allow
you know promotion of leftist ideologies
but as far as what you're saying
like is there a type of content we're
looking for they did say
look for right-wing extreme extremism
globally that might lead to violence
and they did call out spain they said
hey in spain there's a separatist
movement separatist nationalist movement
involving with the boss look out for
violence stemming from that
so in a way they did try to like by
asking the content moderators like
thousands of them to look for certain
things
like we're going to be we we get bored
we see hundreds of posts a day
we probably do 100 200 jobs a day so by
feeding us information by telling us to
look for certain things
it kind of sways things a certain way
were your co-workers progressive or
leftist or what
some of them were some were were right
wing some were more conservative there's
two guys i worked with who were actually
in the original video with project
veritas
jose mourinho and uh his his friend and
we um we had conversations i sat with
them towards the last couple months at
work
um so there i mean there was a pretty
diverse group of people
but um all the leadership i noticed were
more
left-leaning yeah so sean browner for
example was a huge bernie sanders
supporter
the reason i ask is because you know
when i worked for some of these media
companies
it seems like their goal is to hire
people who are progressive left-leaning
and then let them do their thing you
know if they don't need to tell you
to go after conservatives if you're
already biased you know
so i i that's why i asked but it doesn't
seem like they were doing that doesn't
seem like they were they were hiring
people
you know they're just hiring it seems
like they're hiring hiring regular
people
i think for promotions i think they
definitely did take that into account
what's crazy too is the summer
after i started that june or july they
actually made us link our personal
facebook accounts to continue working
wow wow and some people were tracking
you they said the excuse was so that we
didn't accidentally action our friends
content like what's the probability of
it right
yeah so it freaked a lot of people out
because a lot of people didn't have a
facebook account
but but yeah i applied for a promotion a
couple times never got it i applied to
the policy team
with the same team with sean browder and
i have a degree
and a lot of these people were young
like in the early 20s fresh out of high
school didn't have a degree
so i think for promotions they
definitely did take um
ideology into account interesting do you
feel like they
because of your politics or just because
you didn't fit
in with like their culture
they didn't give you a promotion or they
held you back or what yeah i think i
think it's
probably the politics about it um i mean
they they
in the interviews they said hey as a
part of the policy team you're going to
be interfacing with the client a lot
so i mean if you're if if you're a
higher up if you're hiring someone for
the policy team and you know they're
going to be interacting a lot with a
client
why would you promote a a right wing or
conservative person
if i mean if you're trying to protect
it's really similar to what i was told
when i worked for a fusion side with the
audience look the people who come to us
are progressive therefore we give them
you know we want to give them what they
want
and so that seems seems to make sense
yeah based on what you were doing
uh i mean i asked you already uh do you
think there was do you think they swung
an election
do you think what they did helped the
democrats win
in the midterms in 2018 yeah definitely
100 percent i mean
they just think about it's it's about
gathering information and intel
so i mean you have for example
just an example this past fall you had
their ukraine whistleblower
and facebook's guidance was to delete
that and that was on the front lines
when that happened
you were at facebook yeah when so we
can't say the ukraine whistleblower's
name on youtube right now such nonsense
this is this is active censorship if we
say this person's name they will cut the
feed
i have videos on youtube that are in
this
weird state that doesn't exist anywhere
else on youtube
so what happens is if you break the
rules on youtube they'll delete your
post
if it's not a rule breaking thing but
it's like
borderline and they're like well look
they'll do what's called forced
private your video will change to
private so only you can see it
and you can't change it back but you
don't get a strike it's not banned it's
just
one of the steps they have what they did
to my videos on the ukraine
whistleblower this is the guy who
started the whole impeachment process
they are almost just a graphic on the
website
when i go into my videos i have one
video on my main channel one on my
second channel tim cast and tim cast
news
when i go into my videos these the the
videos are there you can see them
but you can't click anything when the
mouse goes over it it doesn't change you
know it's so weird
when you hover over a link it like turns
into a little finger about to click it
nothing and i click and nothing happens
that's what they do
so when when all this is going down i
went on facebook
and i immediately started you know
posting this guy's name like crazy yeah
now here's the crazy thing
i never got any warnings i never got any
like notifications yeah the posts would
just disappear
what that was you yeah that was uh so so
i actually discovered it and we actually
sent it to facebook so facebook
finalized the policy so originally
and this goes back to 2018 because you
know if facebook can
essentially that his name was a was a
republican talking point
you know rand paul tried to mention his
name on fox news he said in the senate
yeah exactly a senator named this guy
because of his potential ties
to democrats his lawyers the statements
they made and there was also a statement
made about him that had nothing to do
with impeachment or whistleblowing
yeah you could not say his name no
matter what there was a c-span video
a senator american senator on the senate
floor said
to the american people this guy and this
guy were overheard
saying they wanted to remove trump had
nothing to do with the whistleblowing
that video got removed from youtube so
it really wasn't for
to protect him as a whistleblower it was
it was it was deleting a republican
talking point that's what it was plain
and simple
so when we first discovered i ran across
this job
and i was talking to my co-worker skyler
about it and we're like hey what should
we do
this guy's you know a whistleblower or
whatever
and so we raised it to our local policy
team and
and we made they made an interim
decision for the next six hours to
delete it
under our privacy policy because they
thought that he was undercover law
enforcement
and i have screenshots of that exact
same policy wait wait they
thought the whistleblower was an
undercover law enforcement yeah
i mean he literally worked for the cia
yeah he wasn't undercover
no and so that was the initial decision
from our local policy team
and then six hours later facebook said
okay we'll continue deleting it but
we're gonna delete it under this generic
part of the policy called coordinating
harm
so there's nothing in the wording of
that policy at all that relates to
whistleblowers
uh so it was just delete coordinating
harm other so it's just some generic
part of it
but i have you know conversations i was
recording filming at the time when i had
those conversations with skyler
my other co-workers and i have a really
good analysis of it written up
but yeah it's mind-blowing you were
deleting posts i was deleting all day
so they feed them into our queue so they
do a proactive pull and they pull in so
they can search whatever name it is
they pull it into our queue and all day
i'd get like 100 jobs like that just
delete delete
did was do you have a touch screen no it
was just your mouse
so you're literally like clicking
clicking because the pose was probably
crazy like people are probably saying
this guy's name
thousands of times per hour yeah
yeah and then we had shortcut keys so it
was like two seven seven right yeah yeah
oh wow yeah so much easier wow thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 p.m so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time